Salut ! Quand j'ai lancé le Mental Vlog, je me suis dis tout le monde sait ce que c'est que le mentalisme, tout le monde c'est ce qu'est un mentaliste.
Je me suis aperçu que ce n'était pas forcément le cas.
Du coup lundi je vous ai posé la question sur Facebook: "Pour vous, qu'est-ce qu'un mentaliste ?"
J'ai lu toutes vos réponses sur les deux Facebook, vous avez été très nombreux et très nombreuses à répondre
et vos réponses étaient... [rires] surprenantes.
"Lire dans les pensées des autres". Une image très classique.
"Quelqu'un qui puisse lire toutes les émotions et les pensées".
Un classique que propose Tiffany, que vous avez vu dans deux vidéos d'ailleurs.
"Manipulation pour coucher avec une femme, évidemment".
Alors là c'est drôle ! C'est Aude, une fille qui dit qu'un mentaliste est quelqu'un qui va te manipuler pour coucher avec toi.
Donc selon toi, l'alcool est un mentaliste... Aude, du coup à chaque fois que tu fais une soirée et que tu ramène le mauvais mec à la maison
le lendemain tu te dis: "Non mais attends... à tous les coups il était mentaliste en fait !"
Ce qui est étrange c'est que je pensais que c'était un fantasme de mec, mais Marie te dit la même chose.
"Manipulation pour draguer et mettre une femme dans son lit".
En plus à chaque fois ce n'est pas juste pour draguer, c'est pour coucher. Il y a une vraie finalité !
Je rigole mais Marie avait une autre hypothèse, beaucoup plus valorisante:
"Il existe surement des mentalistes vengeurs, serial killer, qui tue tous les gens qui mentent."
Ce qui est terrible c'est que je prends tous ces commentaires là pour moi.
Parce que je me dis quand vous avez commencé à regarder les vidéos, ce sont les clichés que vous aviez sur les mentalistes.
"Est-ce qu'un mentaliste qui cherche ce à quoi il pensait, c'est un skizo ?"
Cette phrase est beaucoup trop dure à lire...
"Selon moi le groupe de mots "les mentalistes" cachent deux qualités essentielles d'un mentaliste.
En effet à travers ce groupe de mots on peut deviner "l'emmental" et "liste"."
"l'emmental" et "liste"...
Apparemment tout le monde trouve ça normal...
"On peut faire référence à l'emmental, car à l'inverse de celui-ci le mentaliste n'a jamais de trou de mémoire".
Ca c'est de la vanne Ludivine !
Le pire c'est pas que ça me fasse rire, c'est la conversation que vous avez lancé sur ce sujet.
"Certains diraient que c'est cheesy comme raisonnement, en tout cas grâce à toi on s'en est payé un bonne tranche,
Le mentaliste fait fondre les certitudes, l'emmentaliste doit se méfier des rappeurs."
[rires] Je ne m'en souvenais plus de celle-ci !
"Fabien fait parti du gratin des mentalistes, nous ne parlerons pas de saucisses, ça suffit j'arrête".
Oui je t'en supplie arrête.
"On peut comté sur l'emmentaliste pour savoir si Mozart est là..."
Ouh !
"Cette fois c'est vraiment fini, sinon je ne m'arrêterai plus..."
Oui ne le relancez pas en fait.
Si j'avais eu le temps de faire un montage, j'aurais trouvé ta photo Tanguy, je t'aurais fait parler avec les lèvres, et à la fin
j'aurais mis le Thug life avec les lunettes et...
[chante]
Il ne faut plus jamais que j'essaie de chanter... Plus jamais !
"Il faut absolument un regard louche. Un mentaliste a un regard qui nous fait peur, et aussi il doit être caché dans l'ombre
et ne laisser passer que son nez ou ses mains pour nous manipuler... Il peut avoir un chat, mais seulement si le chat a un regard louche..."
T'es partie beaucoup trop loin. Je pense que tu es partie du coté de vaisseaux de la vierge Marie, les vaisseaux spatiaux évidemment.
Damien, lui normal, qui me voit comme Alakazam, un pokémon.
"Au poker, c'est le type qui fait ce genre de tête et qui sait qu'il a gagné avant même d'avoir distribué les cartes".
Ce message de Julien est accompagné d'une photo.
Je me suis dis: "Mon pote t'as géré quand même pour faire la photo" même moi j'aurais pas fait ça...
"Pour moi un mentaliste est un fou qui n'arrête de me bluffer à chaque vidéo et qui je pense a des pouvoirs reçus par les vaisseaux de la vierge Marie
c'est un élu pour tester les hommes et leurs cerveaux."
Florient, on avait dit qu'on en parlait pas de ça...
On avait qui que ça restait entre toi, moi et le Christ cosmique, alias Merlin l'enchanteur.
Chut !
"C'est un détecteur de mensonges. Un genre de mère à l'esprit aiguisé à qui tu ne feras pas croire que tu trouves sa soupe
poireaux/pommes de terre délicieuse. "Si c'est bon ça va"
Paulette, mes dons de mentaliste me font dire que tu as un problème à résoudre avec la soupe pomme de terre/poireaux, de ta mère évidemment !
Ou alors avec tes enfants qui ne veulent jamais manger ta soupe pommes de terre/poireaux alors qu'ils te disent "mais si c'est bon !"
"Il est au-dessus des dieux. Même au-dessus des magiciens. Et il s'habille toujours en noir, et il pense souvent qu'il est énigmatique, alors qu'en fait il est ennuyeux..."
Là aussi Julien David, je ne sais pas quel mentaliste est venu à ton anniversaire quand tu étais petit, mais apparemment il t'as traumatisé.
"Il se touche le front avec un doigt. Je ne sais pas d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont avec les triangles et les carrés ou les vagues,
même mon fils d'un an a arrêté.
"Ils écrivent une lettre par page A4"
C'est vrai qu'en spectacle on écrit toujours une lettre par page.
"Ils se font chier à apprendre des dico ou des libres chiants, à la lettre près, par cœur. Même les numéros des pages y passent.
"Ils servent de mémo à courses, il servent aussi de calculatrice scientifique mais pas graphique, ils ont un regard froid, et regardent le front en avant, la bouche constipée sur leurs affiches."
Bien qu'ils connaissent la réponse depuis le début, ils prennent un malin plaisir à mettre 10 minutes à la donner, en marquant un silence de 15 secondes tous les 3 mots, sur la musique de "qui veut gagner des millions"
"Ils ne font jamais d'erreur, car les erreurs sont prévues, ils prédisent les numéros du loto mais pas un seul mentaliste n'a jamais gagné..."
Le comble; ils "espèrent avoir du monde à leurs spectacles, car en réalité ils n'en savent rien à l'avance ! Hahaha !"
Willow, comme la plupart des choses que tu as mises sont vraies permet moi d'aller m'asseoir dans un coin et de déprimer pendant quelques jours...
Ainsi, le prochain Mental Vlog ne sera que lundi prochain...
"Pourquoi tu fais ce job, alors que tu peux jouer au loto tous les 4 matins et gagner ta vie comme ça ?"
"Quand on a affaire à un mentaliste, je pense que nous avons peur d'être dévisagé rapidement, on peut se faire démasqué lors d'un mensonge, etc."
"D'autres personnes vont devenir parano pensant que tu lis carrément dans le cerveau des gens.
Le mentaliste si on ne sait pas le travail qu'il y a derrière peut être prit comme un être plus intelligent que tout les autres.
Du coup ça le fait paraître hors norme, et peut faire fantasmer les femmes."
On en revient quand même au fait qu'à chaque fois ce sont les femmes qui projettent ça...
Je suis même d'ailleurs très étonné, bravo les mecs ! Je n'ai pas eu un seul commentaire sur la drague, sur la manipulation envers les filles.
Ce que je retiens au final, c'est que j'ai un regard louche, que je sers de post-it portable, de calculatrice portable, ça je savais déjà.
Que vous avez peur que je vous manipule, que je lise dans vos pensées, que je vous mettent dans mon lit. Apparemment, il va falloir que j'achète un grand lit !
Que je passe ma vie à lire des trucs chiants.
C'est pas tout à fait faux, et c'est pas tout à fait vrai non plus ! C'est une question de point de vue. Moi, ce que je lis je ne le trouve pas chiant.
Et que je suis source de blagues à base de fromage !
Entre la fan page et le profil Facebook, il y a eu plus de 200 messages comme ça. Vraiment c'est cool. C'était un test en fait.
J'avais envie de lancer des vidéos un peu plus interactives. Des vidéos que l'on construirait ensemble !
Je ne savais pas trop si vous alliez y participer. Souvent vous me donnez des thèmes dans les commentaires des vidéos YouTube, ça c'est cool.
Mais pour faire ce genre de vidéo, je trouve que Facebook c'est plus facile car tous les commentaires sont réunis.
Donc lundi je vous poserai une nouvelle question et là j'adapterai je pense la vidéo de jeudi en fonction de toutes vos réponses.
Si cela vous tente !
Merci d'être ici ! Si ce genre de vidéo vous plait vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit...
POUCE EN L'AIR !
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonnez à la chaine.
Et rendez-vus demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !